نعم الان اشتباكات عريفه تدور في هذه
اللحظات تستطيع مشاهده هذا الاشتباك الذي
يندلع في هذه الاثناء الان عند مدخل دوار
السينما تحديدا بالقرب من احد مداخل
المخيم في هذا المكان نستطيع مشاهده
المقاومين الفلسطينيين يتصدون لاقتحام
قوات الاحتلال المتواصل باتجاه مدينه
ومخيم جنين الق قوات قامت بالخروج من احد
مداخل المخيم وقامت بالاشتباك مع القوات
ايضا مع الشبان الذين كانوا يتواجدون في
هذه المنطقه وفي ذات الوقت فان سيارات
الاسعاف تتخذ مناطق امنه في هذه اللحظات
نتيجه لاشتباكات عنيفه اندلعت بين قوات
الاحتلال والشبان الفلسطينيين الذين تصدوا
لاقتحام واسعا ل قوات الاحتلال لمدينه
ومخيم جنين هذا الاقتحام هو الاقتحام
الثام عشر لمدينه ومخيم جنين منذ السابع
من اكتوبر
وهذا الاقتحام تركز بشكل اساسي باتجاه
المنطقه الواقعه في جنوب وجنوب غرب مخيم
جنين وكذلك مدينه جنين وتحديدا في حاره
الدمج تلك المنطقه التي شهدت اشتباكات
عنيفه بين قوات الاحتلال وبين المقاومين
الفلسطينيين ايض ايض بعدما كان كانت كتيبه
جنين قد نفذت مسيره
بالاسلحه من من قبل افرادها ومقاوم هنا في
هذه المنطقه في وسط مدينه جنين اعلنوا
خلالها استمرارهم بالتصدي لقوات الاحتلال
ومؤازرته هذا الاشتباك يبدو انه اشتباك
اشتباك واسع بين قوات الاحتلال والمقاومين
الفلسطينيين الذين اكدوا على استمرارهم
بالتصدي لاقتحامات قوات الاحت احتلال
وانها ان قوات الاحتلال لم تتمكن خلال ال
17 اقتحاما السابق من القضاء على هذه
الفصائل الفلسطينيه وكذلك على كتيبه جنين
بشكل اساسي التي تقوم في كل مره تقتحم
فيها قوه الاحتلال بالاشتباك ومواجهه
ال القوات الاحتلال التي تقتحم هذه
المدينه وكذلك مخيم جنين رغم كل ما جرى
خلال الفتره الماضيه من تجريف وتدمير
واستخداما لمسيرات وكذلك ل الجرافات
والعدد الكبير من الاليات التي تقتحم
مدينه جنين نستطيع مشاهده هذه الاوضاع في
هذه اللحظات هنا في المدينه في مدينه جنين
في كذلك في المحيط المخيم هذه المنطقه هي
منطقه فارغه الا من بعض السيارات سيارات
الاسعاف التي تتواجد في المكان نظرا ل
للخطر الشديد الذي تشهده هذه المناطق
نتيجه يضا
وجود قوات الاحتلال المنتشره في اكثر من
منطقه في محيط مخيم ومدينه جنين صفارات
الانذار كانت قد دوت في نعود لنستمع الان
في هذه اللحظات لاصوات اطلاق النار من
حاره الدمج تحديدا من المنطقه الواقعه
غربيه مخيم جنين هذه المنطقه التي لطالما
كانت قد شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه بين قوات
الاحتلال وبين القوات وبين الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وايضا كتيبه جنين وقان استهدفت
كذلك بمسيرات بالصواريخ وتحديدا مسجد
الانصار فيها هي المنطقه الاساسيه التي
تشهد هذه الاشتباكات خلال هذه الليله
لكننا كما رصدنا قبل لحظات هذه الاشتباكات
توسعت الى هنا الى وسط وسط مدينه جنين
نستطيع ان نسمع مجددا اصوات اطلاق النار
من هنا من وسط المدينه حيث يشتبك
المقاومون الفلسطينيون مع قوات الاحتلال
التي تحاول ان تخرج من مناطق تمركزها في
المخيم لتتجه باتجاه المناطق المختلفه في
مدينه جنين والفصائل الفلسطينيه
والمقاومون الفلسطينيون يحاولون ان يمنعوا
قوات الاحتلال من تحقيق هذا الهدف ومن
الوصول الى مدينه جنين وتوسيع رقعه
اشتباكها لا سما وان قوات الاحتلال كانت
عند اجتياحها الواسع لمخيم الجنين وهو
الاجتياح الاكبر منذ عام 2002 الذي جرى في
الثاني عشر والثالث عشر والرابع عشر من
ديسمبر كانت قد قامت باجتياح المنطقه
الشرقيه هذه المنطقه التي تقع خلفي هنا في
هذه المنطقه تحديدا قامت قوات الاحتلال
باجتياحها خلال الايام الاخيره خلال
الاجتياح الاخير وقامت كذلك
بقصفها بالمسيرات هذا الاجتياح الذي قامت
قوات الاحتلال
بتنفيذه خلال هذه ال
خلال هذه الاجتياحات الماضيه وقامت ايضا
بمنع سيارات الاسعاف من الوصول الى المكان
وفرضت عده اجراءات وممارسات خلال اجتياحها
الاخير وهو ما يحاول الشبان القيام به
الان من منع قوات الاحتلال من الوصول الى
المنطقه الشرقيه ومن المناطق المختلفه
لقوات للمدينه لمدينه جنين لعدم تمدد هذا
الاشتباك وعدم تمدد هذا الاجتياح الجاري
في هذه اللحظات لمدينه ومخيم جنين هذه
السيارات التي نراها الان هي سيارات
الاسعاف التي تقوم قوات الاحتلال بفرض
اجراءات خاصه عليها عند كل اقتحام تمنعها
من الوصول والتقدم الى المناطق التي تشهد
اشتباكات تقوم بفرض التنسيق عليها للوصول
الى اي مصاب في المدينه وتقوم كذلك ب
احيانا توقيفها وتفتيشها وتفتيش
المقاومين ايضا او الفرق عفوا التي تقوم
بالعمل في داخل سيارات الاسعاف وهو ايضا
ما كنا قد رصدناه خلال الاجتياحات الكثيره
الماضيه لمدينه ومخيم جنين اها